it's a day to reinforce the importance
of a free press after a year when 67
journalists globally have been killed in
the line of duty
but violence is only one of the threats
they face Wall Street Journal reporter
Evan gerskovich was arrested in Russia
on March 29th he's being held on charges
of Espionage accusations the newspaper
vehemently denies that's appalling and
it's a it's a gut punch
and people are feeling that it's
personal
and there's also a bigger thought that
as a reporter this could be you Al
Jazeera has two journalists imprisoned
in Egypt but the Network's bureau chief
for the Americas had some good news
it was detained in Egypt
without trial the good news is that he
was released two days ago thank you
Marcia linajad is an iranian-american
journalist exiled from her Homeland we
understand each other and we have to be
United she spoke about the importance of
recognizing the three imprisoned Iranian
women whose reporting led to massive
demonstrations for women's rights they
are the recipients of this year's
Guillermo Cano World Press Freedom prize
they actually risk their lives and they
took action against the Islamic Republic
this is what we need to see across the
globe otherwise the Islamic Republic has
no reason to stop jailing and torturing
its own journalists and activists Al
Jazeera journalist Shireen abuaklay is
also being remembered with the screening
of an Al Jazeera documentary about how
she was shot and killed by Israeli
forces as she covered their actions
nearly one year ago
to date no one has been held accountable
but the Forum was not just about the
physical risk to journalists it also
addressed the challenges of maintaining
free speech in an era of disinformation
and the harassment of so-called
influencers online like Philippe Neto of
Brazil whose YouTube channel has 40
million followers
being accused of the things I was I was
accused was the hardest thing I ever had
to deal with
and it's one thing they try to do when
they can't corrupt you they try to
corrupt your soul and your image in the
eyes of the audience World Press Freedom
Day is about more than highlighting The
Perils of journalists it is a reminder
that the free flow of information is
essential to preserving everyone's
rights
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the United
Nations